good morning this is an Barker I'm
actually in Tempe Arizona today so good
morning or good afternoon wherever you
are my my former roles actually were as
deputy director of the National Cancer
Institute and they are I was able to do
a number of things that i'm going to be
reviewing today i am currently at
arizona state university where i am the
co-director of complex adaptive systems
here and i'm also directive director of
transformative healthcare networks and
i'm going to be talking to you today
about molecular based medicine what we
call personalized medicine or precision
medicine it's got a lot of names but
essentially its molecular based medicine
and I'm going to ask the question is is
this our best hope to finally defeat
cancer and i'll give you the take-home
message I'm pretty optimistic but there
are some issues and we're going to go
through those in some detail today I
encourage you to ask questions as we go
through the talk today and we'll try to
answer all of your questions and clarify
as we go through if that would be
helpful so so welcome to everybody and
those folks that were just on with Chuck
Peru I hope you learned an enormous
amount about what the great things that
Chuck has done for the Cancer Genome
Atlas in terms of breast cancer so um
today we're going to we're going to walk
through several areas that I think are
going to be very important in
determining whether or not this is our
best hope for finally defeating cancer
what is to talk about some of the
realities that we're facing in this
field and it's a very old field actually
goes back way beyond 1971 when we
actually when richard nixon nixon
actually approved the national cancer
institute the work started well before
then and continues obviously to this day
with a very very big enterprise behind
it including the National Cancer
Institute and certainly the private
sector and increasingly foundations and
others working in the research arena
the state of the science is is evolving
quite rapidly and driven in large
measure by advanced technologies most
especially whole genome sequencing and
next-gen sequencing which we'll talk a
bit more about and we want to talk about
sort of how do we how do we evolve this
strategy in molecular based medicine and
why do we think it's really important
and why we think that we should continue
down this road and if we continue down
this road where should we be looking and
what should we be looking for so and
then finally let's look at the near term
and the and a future in terms of things
that we have to do to really realize
this potential so so to get started
let's face some realities here cancer is
an extraordinarily daunting disease not
just the nature of this disease the
heterogeneity of the disease the
complexity etc but just the sheer
numbers if you look at cancer in the
United States we have about 1.6 million
new cases that we're going to diagnose
this year and I should tell you that's
substantially increasing men have about
a one in two lifetime chance of getting
cancer in women one and three five
hundred and eighty thousand plus people
will die this year from this disease
it's it's an enormous number and again
that's increasing about that's it's
going to be about twenty five percent of
our living population today and that's
that's an enormous number when you start
thinking at the size of our country an
interesting statistic that is a grim
reality for this country because of the
baby boomer generation is that
seventy-seven percent of cancer is
diagnosed in individuals over the age of
55 and if you think about the fact that
about 10,000 people are turning 65 each
day in the US you can start to imagine
that cancer is going to increase and its
projected increase somewhere in the
neighborhood of thirty percent in the
next 15 to 20 years and that's that's
all very bad news but the good news is
that they're about 13.7 million
survivors today
many more survivors and much of that is
due to some of the targeted treatment
that will be talking about the cost of
cancer is is well over 200 billion
dollars a year and that that's going to
increase enormously this is one of the
largest problems we have in healthcare
today and finally mortality rates
overall have not shifted all that much
starting to shift a little bit in the
last five or six years but not so much
into 1950s due to the increased numbers
of people getting cancer and as we'll
talk about later that's an area where we
have to focus the reality is just not a
u.s. reality this is a world problem and
when I was at the NC on we spent a lot
of time talking to other countries about
their cancer problem and as you can see
in 2008 there were about 7.6 million
cancer deaths projected by 2020 there
will be about 10.3 million and it's
going up significantly from there in if
you look at 16 million new cases in that
same year that's going to be an enormous
burden for the world not just for the US
or for Europe or / China but if you
think about China China has 350 million
smokers and as you know at least in our
country and around the world about a
third of cancer is caused by smoking so
this is a huge issue in China and will
be and become more of an issue as time
goes on so one of the other realities we
face is is metastatic disease as you can
see these numbers are a little better
than when I made the slide about a
little over a year ago but if you have
if you have metastatic disease at the
time of diagnosis your chances of
recovering and surviving your disease
might become much much less and regional
disease is still much more curable than
distant metastases and for some of these
tumors like pancreatic cancer we really
still don't do very well in terms of
really saving cancer patients and these
are areas that are in
this focus for 44 Institute's like the
National Cancer Institute and for many
of the survivors groups so that's all
that's all about the daunting statistics
that we're going to consider for the
moment and that's heaven knows that's
enough but the reality of what this is
actually led to over the many years that
we've been trying to actually cure this
disease and freak this disease more
effectively is that we have a pipeline
or a drug development process that
hasn't done very well so if you look at
this slide you'll see that from the time
we start in the discovery say of small
molecules to improving approving
actually a drug FDA approving a drug it
costs us about a billion dollars and it
takes about 15 to 20 years now that is
in large measure due to the complexity
of this disease and the lack of
effective biomarkers there are other
reasons but the heterogeneity of the
disease and complexity for cancer is has
been a daunting problem and remains a
daunting problem even as we move toward
molecular medicine if you if you think
if you think that it would be
appropriate and you have questions as we
go through this talk please ask them as
we go along so we don't have all of our
questions at the end so let's talk a
little bit now about the state of cancer
research and if you look at where we all
started down this road it started when
all the way back in nineteen ninety when
there was there was the national attempt
to sequence the human genome which
turned into a major major project a very
successful project one of the most
probably one of the most transformative
projects of our time if you look at what
that project actually really enabled it
was the ability for us to identify these
changes in jeans and changes in
chromosomes actually at every level of
the genome whether it was copy number
changes big changes in their genome
are in the chromosomes RNA expression
micro RNAs which are much more recent
but extraordinarily important point
mutations the proteome the epigenome etc
so if you go if you go to if you go to
the literature today you will find all
of these areas being exploring and if
you think about how far we've come in
terms of knowing the numbers of genes
knowing the number of base pairs in DNA
and knowing that we are still pretty
dismal in terms of knowing function only
about fifty percent of what we know
about the genome in terms of mutations
or changes in the genome have actually
enabled us to understand function so
this is our challenge understanding
changes in the genome is step one
understanding of functional changes that
occur as a consequence is is step two
through whatever and where we've got a
lot of work to do there and that in fact
is probably our biggest issue in terms
of realizing the promise of molecular
based medicine the other thing I want to
point out at this stage and it is an
area of research for the cancer
community has been for many many years
and that is that cancer occurs in
context so the microenvironment the
architectural issues related to how DNA
gets expressed or hug gets interpreted
by a cell within a cell is incredibly
important the last thing I'll point out
is that you know this is a this is a
trip that we haven't been on all that
long the first oncogene was actually
discovered in only in 1986 so this
progress has been pretty rapid and if
you think about where we are now versus
where we can go I think we can expect
exponential progress at this stage so I
want I want to pause here for a second
and think about what it is that really
started us on this road and and really
catalyzed more thinking about what how
can we actually understand the genome
and is understanding the genome our best
ticket to really eliminating suffering
and death due to cancer hopefully curing
more cancer so this is a drug that was
developed in and approved in 2002
gleevec imatinib for chronic myelogenous
leukemia and this is a very interesting
story and one that is worth knowing a
lot about because it has matured and
today we know a great deal more about
this drug and a great deal more about
this particular change in the genome
which has allowed us to understand a lot
more about other diseases so if you look
at this particular change in the genome
it's a fusion genome it's an exchange
actually between two chromosomes
chromosome 9 and chromosome 22 to create
a new construct actually and that new
construct leads to a new protein that
new protein as brian druker and his
colleagues found out when they started
working on this particular alteration
the genome drives a great deal of what
happens in chronic myelogenous leukemia
and so that drug was approved in 2002
and lo and behold many of those patients
many of whom actually were near death
were virtually cured now that was the
good news the bad news is cancer is
extraordinarily intelligent I put that
in quotation marks disease so there are
all kinds of backup mechanisms that
cancers evolved and so we do have
resistance in a in a percentage of these
patients and we now have second and
third-generation drugs to treat these
patients but this was a really
instructive point and I think one that
influenced a lot of what came after in
terms of expecting that we would find a
lot more of these kinds of changes in
the genome that hasn't proven to be the
case but we have found one more recently
the be rap gene which actually is is
turning out to be a very important
change on the genome as well and we'll
come back to that one of the minute but
this has been it was instructive in for
a couple of other reasons this
particular drug was very effective in
CML but as it turns out it's all
so effective against another change in
the genome called secant so this
particular drug this is an fdg-pet
response to gist or gastrointestinal
tumors this drug actually is very
effective against these tumors and
actually a Madame is effective against
several kinds of tumors now and that's a
story that's going to be very
interesting if you start thinking about
this here's one change in the genome
that the magnums working against and
another one that it's also working
against it's it's it's a very
interesting sort of dynamic that's that
we're beginning to understand that these
genomes the changes some of these
changes are going to be common across
several cancers some are going to be
very unique so you've got to look at you
got to look at the drug very carefully
and and and tested in clinical trials
against several diseases so we in 2003
Francis Collins that I had a
conversation we had many conversations
with our ward at the National Cancer
Institute is it time given given what
had gone on in discovering what we knew
about the human genome from the Human
Genome Project is it time to sit down
and talk about doing a big science
project for the cancer genome and the
answer was yes we decided to do that in
2003 so we set up the Cancer Genome
Atlas um some people like it some people
don't like it it's big science I
personally believe that we are at a
stage in science where we need to
balance big science and our one or
individual investigator initiated
science the goal here was to identify
all the genomic changes in up to what
became 20 different cancers and I think
you heard from Chuck Peru on the last
talk about some of the things that TCGA
is accomplished in breast cancer since
was a very big project everything in
this project was highly controlled from
the samples and the quality of the
samples to pretty much everything about
the data how the data was actually
deposited how the data elements were
selected how we manage that
in terms of the data repository and we
also had analytical teams to work on the
data and we had technology development
that both NHGRI and NCI funded during
that period so very big science a very
big project and many publications now in
nature cataloging and various mutations
that we have found in TCGA some very
interesting some confirming what we
already knew which is an extremely
important step when you think about the
fact that thousands of people have
worked on these genomes and we need we
need confirmatory kinds of projects like
this to ensure ourselves that this is
that these data are real so we use
multiple technologies here we started
with with Sanger sequencing we worked
our way through and actually adopted
next-gen sequencing and we looked at
various states of the genome RNA
obviously changes in the DNA the
epigenome we did not consider we did not
work on the proteome in this project
specifically some of our colleagues did
in some of the center's and there were a
number of centers obviously working
together on this project and literally
hundreds of investigators so if you
think about the kinds of things that
come out of projects like this and their
other projects like TCGA now out there
this was this was actually the first
tumor we reported on which was GBM or
glioblastoma multiforme a it's an
extraordinarily lethal tumor as you know
at the time we started this
investigation with TCGA there wasn't
much in the literature that actually
would inform us about this tumor in
terms of how to treat at how to diagnose
it so what we were able to do is as we
as we worked as we worked our way
through this we were able to map these
map these changes in the genome pretty
systematically and this is expression
RNA expression and we were able to
actually sub classify these tumors and
this has been done said
with ovarian cancer and other cancers
but essentially it also allowed us to
take the pathways and as you can see
here the rtk arrests pi3 kinase pathway
the p53 pathway the RB pathway these
were pathways that we knew a lot about
but we were able to map the genomes and
the changes in the genome cities
pathways which substantially improved
and increase our confidence that for
example the tyrosine kinases we know
they're important in cancer we know
they're important targets but this was a
great way to start to look at this and
there were new genes found here and this
is this is probably one of the best
databases out there or GBM many many
investigators now working on this tumor
and lots of new drugs coming along and
being tested for GBM unfortunately not
moving nearly as quickly as we would
like but I think in the next four to
five years you will see some significant
changes in the white GBM is diagnosed
and treated so if you look at what TCGA
did and several other of the large
genome projects including an
international project that actually used
a lot of the learning curves that we had
developed in TCGA the international
cancer genome project being run by tub
by Tom Hudson out of Canada but if you
look at what this has created we've kind
of created a sequencing tsunami now I
mean we have we have a lot of sequencing
going on and we're sequencing not just
cancer but certainly across many and
almost all diseases now but if you start
to if you start to look at if you start
to look at this it's really based not
just on the reduced reduced cost of
sequencing genomes but also on the
amount of information it's coming from
the genomes and nher is is recommending
that you know that we are to start to
really begin to systematically look at
this data and and are creating new
approaches to that for analysis and and
other approaches but it's projected that
by the end of 2014 there will be a
million genomes and
the total total global output is going
to be about 28 petabytes of data by 2014
that's an enormous amount of sequence an
enormous amount of information we don't
know how to manage that and it's a huge
challenge for us in cancer probably the
biggest challenge we have right now and
if you look at who's producing all this
data it's pretty much coming from
everywhere from the international
projects from TCGA from pretty much
everywhere and the nci-designated Cancer
Centers are engaged the pharma bio
companies certainly engaged and so we do
from the sequencing tsunami we now have
a big data tsunami and you hear a lot
about Big Data these days very important
and particularly important in terms of
cancer so increasingly it is about Big
Data increasingly many of you out there
that are working in the genomespace know
how challenging this is in terms of
analysis it's it's a it's a huge problem
and one that as I say NCI is working on
NIH is working on certainly lots of
private initiatives in this area
especially also in Europe and there
there's a book out that you haven't
picked it up yet you might want to look
at it this is now becoming known as sort
of the fourth paradigm science but
essentially this is what biomedicine is
going to become or is quickly becoming
information and big data is in fact
going to be the future biomedicine so
those of you out there that trained in
differential equations and having
forgotten your ear computational skills
you're going to be well served in the
future because this is it's going to
become increasingly important we don't
have enough people trained in this space
I wish we had a great deal more I know
many of our colleges and universities
are trying to catch up in this area now
so if you look at the data explosion in
cancer and in biomedicine overall it
takes three different forms in terms of
variety there's just different forms of
the things that we're sequencing and
finding out about the genome the sheer
eight or the velocity is almost
exponential now and the amount of volume
as i said is is absolutely unprecedented
so if you look at all the data types and
you put all of this together in terms of
the multi multi dimensionality of this
data 28 petabytes that we were talking
about before starts to look realistic
and pretty daunting in terms of the
amount of analysis we have to do and as
I said we now only know about fifty
percent of the functional changes that
are involved with the data that we know
something about so very very big problem
so the beauty of this era that we're
living in right now and I think we'll
all look back on this era as one where
we're beginning to open a new window
into understanding the complexity of
this disease this big data really if we
manage it correctly and we put the right
teams together I think we can start to
decon dilute the complexity of this
disease in ways that we wouldn't have
guessed even five years ago and I'm
going to spend a minute on that at the
end of a talk so the way we're starting
to think about cancer and the way I like
to think about cancer in the way I'd
like you to start thinking about cancer
is as follows this is a complex
information driven system under the
influence of evolution and it evolves in
space over time now that's a lot to
think about but I would challenge you to
start thinking about the
four-dimensional genome not just the two
dimension genome because whatever the
cause on the side of your screen it's my
left I don't know if it's your left it
can be inherited which is not not a
large percentage of cancer but it can be
caused by so many different things
including smoking as we mentioned before
and certainly diet but wherever you
start in terms of the changes in the
genome everything after that is actually
under the influence of evolution all the
way up to the malignant state but this
is a system composed of many subsystems
so we need to
start thinking about this to understand
function we're going to have to
understand a lot more about the
four-dimensional genome so if you look
at the way we see out saw patients and
you see patients as you sequence them
even though if you look at this going
back to the sub B subtyping of GBM every
every line on there actually is an
individual patient no two patients are
going to be exactly the same but there
are common features in these pathways
that unites them almost like snowflakes
I put snowflakes on one side of the
screen here because as you know in
physics there are there are some really
interesting structural features and
physics of snowflakes that make them
look very much the same on a gross basis
but very very different when you get
down to them to the Nano space and so
the same thing may very well we may need
to start to thinking of the patients and
of the science of what we're dealing
with in this same way so the the
pathways that we're talking about are
quite common the extent to which
patients changes occurs in those
pathways is quite different so finally I
want to I want to turn to the question
that we asked when we started this
conversation and that is is molecular
base notice that our best chance to
defeat cancer and I am going to give you
a maybe right now because I want to I
want to bring up a few issues and their
issues that we all have to deal with to
realize the potential of whatever we
have here and I think we do have an
extraordinarily good opportunity to do a
lot more about this disease so there are
several barriers I'm going to just I'm
going to talk about two of those
barriers this morning but one that's
close to my heart is this issue of
high-quality data best practices and
standards for the areas that are driving
biomarker development and and biomarkers
are actually signals of either normal
seeing in a cellular or
a process that actually signals that
something is okay or something is not
okay in the case of disease the end but
there are other their other barriers
here like as i said before translating
data and the knowledge is probably one
of our biggest barriers clinical trials
and realigning and redesigning clinical
trials to accommodate a personalized
medicine approach economic realities of
this who's going to pay for it engaging
patients this has to be patient centric
and then some of the ethical issues that
surround us a whole issue of molecular
medicine all things that have to be
dealt with but i want to talk a little
bit about this issue of standards and
quality in this space and then also how
do we talk and think about this
four-dimensional genome so we can do a
lot more than we're currently doing so
if i if i take you back to the Cancer
Genome Atlas for a second we learned a
lot in that particular project about the
value of standards and the value of
actually having high-quality tissues of
actually sourcing those tissues in ways
that we're there they're collected under
standard operating procedures it turns
out to be pretty important and even
though technology is moving very quickly
now the significance of reproducibility
of data and reproducibility of findings
is incredibly important especially again
around biochemical biomarkers and I
would argue that quality tissues and
quad access to quality tissues is going
to be critical and is going to be more
and more difficult in the future because
we're getting better and better actually
at preserving preserving tissues and
also in preserving life so we're we're
by the time we get around to taking out
many of these tumors we've actually
shrunk them and so we're we're actually
preserving life but we're also we're
also decreasing the amount of tissue
that were going to have available so but
one thing we learned here and it was a
learning curve that cost us time and it
also cost us resources was that at that
time and I'm not sure how much has
changed only about a third of our
tissues in the country were good enough
to use in the early going of the Cancer
Genome Atlas and
so quality is important and I think it's
now become very important to most of you
out there and the second area that is I
think reflects some of these problems
and not just in tissues but also lack of
standards in in the technology space is
that we are not very good at developing
biomarkers and well we're not very good
at all in developing biomarkers we've
discovered about 150,000 in the
literature about a thousand of those
have actually made it through the FDA
only about 1.3 per year since the early
90s and the reasons are complex but a
lot of them have to do with
reproducibility of data and the quality
of the analytes that we're working on so
this has to be fixed otherwise we can
like all the discoveries we want but we
have to have decent biomarkers to to
pair up with the kind of drugs that we
want to get approved so if you look at
what we're going to do about the
biomarker problem and the standards
problem overall for biomarkers we don't
currently have a prospective way to
think are through it think our way
through a pipeline to actually develop
an end-to-end approach to biomarker
development it just doesn't exist it's
been done piecemeal over many years and
general Woodcock who's the director of
the center for drugs at the FDA has said
it's an on FDA's job to develop the
standards for biomarkers it's the job of
the affected communities so i'll just
mention one of the things that we have
done here at arizona state university in
actually in collaboration with many
partners the critical path Institute the
International Genome consortium Mayo
Clinic t Jen and many national groups as
well now is to take this problem on so
we've developed something called the
National biomarker development lines
will be launching that in January of
2014 and our mission actually as this
pipeline indicates is to create a
standard set of standards and best
practices so that we can actually come
up with a prospective predictable
in the end pipeline for the express
purpose of bringing rigor and
predictability to biomarker development
we think that will really really help
our communities to get their drugs
approved to get their biomarkers
approved and accelerate the pace by
which we can get these targeted drugs
into patients so it's a big tent if any
of you interested in joining me in this
and joining our colleagues in this just
email me and we love to have you join us
so coming back to this issue of
complexity I want to spend my final few
minutes here on talking about how this
cancer community can embrace complexity
and think about think more deeply about
the four-dimensional genome this is
where progress will be made in my
opinion so coming back to cancer as a
complex system and all the excuse me all
the other discussion that we've had
about this sorry so maybe you can still
get you can still make mistakes when you
have everything under your control there
the coming back to this idea that cancer
is a complex system it's not just a
complex system in the sense that you're
looking at it in a linear fashion you
have to look at it in terms of the
subsystems and the interaction that goes
on in in three-dimensional space and
over time and and time is a big
component in cancer when you think about
it because it takes and with many of
these cancers it takes decades to
develop these diseases so we need to
understand a lot more about how these
changes in the genome get expressed in
terms of this four-dimensional idea and
if we can do that then we'll start to
take what we now look at is pathways and
this is a hand and Weinberg slide that
lots of people show but essentially
cancer isn't is an emergent system it's
it's actually the consequence of the
interaction of so many of these pathways
over time and in space so just looking
at these pathways as we diagram them
today it's convenient but it's not that
simple and so we have to start thinking
about these pathways as they interact
and how this disease emergence and so
very very
important for all of us to start
changing our mindset about the linearity
of pathways that's not the way it works
in nature and it's not the way it
certainly works in in the human body so
if you start to think about this and let
me just click quickly through this and
click back sorry this is the problem
with animation so if you start to think
about how information and drive systems
within systems then if you look at
cancer as a system they're all kinds of
length scales starting with cancer it
starts down to their genome or even
below the genome actually at the at the
molecular level or even at the atomic
level we don't do much in cancer at that
level yet but I predict someday we will
but essentially you've got to start
thinking across scales all the way from
DNA up to the organism and if you look
at the variables then you you you're
going to move from the changes in DNA
all the way up to the organism and these
systems abay the laws of physics it
doesn't necessarily explain their
behavior because it's an emergency so
the subsystems can can actually behave
in some way but the emergent system may
behave differently and we see that in
cancer and heterogeneity actually
produces a lot of things that we can't
control so these behaviors that we see
in cancer whether it's the immersion of
misfortunes and metastasis world
resistance are the ability to actually
physically they sell some route from one
place to the other you can't you can't
really explain that by understanding the
components so each of these components
is part of a complex system and I would
argue that's the future how do we
understand complex systems cancer is
information it's decoded in context and
so shape matters context matters
infrastructure matters this is all
information and the information is being
translated between the context of
architecture and DNA and people who
worry about the microenvironment are
starting to really make contributions I
think in this field so I think the
future belongs two teams of people who
are going to work together from
theorists in terms of evolutionary
theory information theory IT and
computational and bioinformaticians and
physics and engineering helping us to
understand some of the physics of these
systems and then biologists who actually
are developmental biologist cancer
biologists etc and I think this
increasing complexity across all of the
areas that we think about from the DNA
up to the organism is going to be the
future of the way we think and work with
this disease and other complex chronic
diseases but cancer is especially going
to be relevant to this kind of approach
so I have guarded optimism that
molecular based medicine is our best
hope to finally defeat cancer I think
we're starting to show some real hope in
that regard and here's the best hope of
all if this is just a list of some drugs
that have been approved for cancer
starting with herceptin which was
actually at first to the targeted drugs
approved all the way back I think in two
thousand if I remember correctly this is
this is actually her to which is an
amplified gene in breast cancer and that
was actually worked on and pushed
forward by Denny Simon at UCLA and is
used very almost universally in breast
cancer today and I'm just going to
highlight a couple of others here
obviously egfr expression in terms of
Erbitux is now is that we have several
approved drugs beyond the list it's on
here k r s is a very interesting example
of understanding the genome in more
detail then we would have thought even
important a few years ago the wild type
of this particular gene these cancers
respond if in fact they are mutated KS
genes they generally do not respond it's
not it's not an absolute guarantee that
if you're wild type that you'll respond
but very major percentage of those
patients do but what's really important
is knowing who's not going to respond so
this is a another example of unapproved
drugs a series of drugs now to treat
this disease for patients
especially with wild-type ke RS more
recently the brf gene discovered many
years ago now has been shown to be very
important in melanoma and we have we
have several drugs now approved from
metastatic melanoma just in the last
five years along with and i should say
all of these drugs have approved
biomarker tests now there are issues
with the tests and one of the things
that are going back to the plans of the
National biomarker development lines we
hope to work out these issues in terms
on building better biomarker test even
her too to this day starts to continues
to be an issue so we'll come back to
we'll come back to that at the end
potentially with questions so I'm
getting the end of my time and I want to
make sure that I have some time to
discuss with you some of these issues so
in the near future here's what I think
some things here are some things that I
think will need to happen to realize
this whole future of personalized
molecular based medicine number one we
have to engage patients in all aspects
of this process this is about
personalized patient-focused medicine
and so we need to do clinical trials and
inform clinical trials with patients and
so engaging patients is going to be
critical and I think more and more
scientists understand that and are
beginning to work with survivors groups
in ways that we haven't done before and
that's going to be very productive we
have to know that our molecular
signatures or our biomarkers are
extremely robust and reproducible now as
you know the literature defensive
literature recently showing that we have
some issues in that regard some actually
a fair percentage of some of the work
done in biomarker science especially
it's not been reproducible and we need
to know that there's no bias and network
at the nadir of high quality etc because
that's the work that's going to get
translated by the pharmaceutical
companies large amount of dollars are
going to be invested and we need to be
very careful that we are in the
discovery community producing robust
data that's translatable and
suddenly producible we need we really
need to start engaging war with
computational experts and long words
that we have this is occurring now it's
I think it's still pretty modest and you
know my my advice is to take a
mathematician to launch and interest
them in your science and interest them
in your data because if we're going to
functionalize this data we have to
engage people who really understand how
to look at data and there are people
that outside our field to know a lot
more about this than we do for example
people who poor cast the weather they
have great models to look at huge big
data sets earthquake monomers I mean so
it may sound a little strange lead The
Economist's there are other people who
know how to look at big data sets we
need to learn from them we need to
engage with them very difficult but
doable and a lot of those people would
love to work with us especially the
googles and and Microsoft folks of the
world those are people who we need to
engage with um we knew we need new and
much better clinical trial models than
we currently have especially for our
biomarker durban clinical trials and we
need we need trials like the I spy two
trial one that I was able to work on and
help to enable it when i was at National
Cancer Institute still involved with
that trial led by law a sermon and Dawn
berry now moving to ice 53 but this is
an adaptive trial that allows us to look
at lots of biomarkers and lots of drugs
if you don't know about ice by two you
can go to the literature there are
several several publications out there
now on ice by one and I spy two and also
the battle trial Alabam md anderson and
other trials there's a new lung cancer
trial coming along as well so another
thing we need is these best practices
standards guidelines for biomarkers
which don't exist again that's something
that I'm taking on and I'm hoping that
some of you will want to join me in that
we need the evolutionary biologist in
volunteer we don't we don't have great
strengths in terms of evolution in
cancer we know that it's very important
but we we haven't thought about how you
actually model to prospectively
understand for example resistance and I
think evolution is incredibly
Orton in terms of understanding
resistance to the Catteni drugs that
we're ministering and then last but not
least for this field to be important
enough for payers to actually pay for it
which is going to be critical whether
you know whether you're in that whether
you're in the payer community or in the
development community or in the
discovery community there has to be a
value proposition here so we we the
scientific community is going to have to
demonstrate the value of the likely
based medicine so that we can we can
actually entice the payers and encourage
the payers to pay for this and that's
not a small issue because the value
proposition me needs to be demonstrated
in very sound ways and in clinical
trials finally in the more distant
future I think a lot of things are going
to change they're going to really
accelerate progress in this space of
molecular based medicine first of all we
need to understand more about the
information that's driving complexity
whether its use of models or actually
sort of the definition of state space as
physicist see it or mathematically
modeling the information that we need
but we need to understand what it is
that is most important in terms of D
convoluting the complexity of this
disease especially the pathways in the
interacting pathways so we can identify
these sensitive nodes which are going to
be our bio signatures in the future I
think so coming back to this idea of
evolution in context we need we need to
actually engage with scientists who
understand and measure bits of
information flow in systems and how
cells make decisions and cells do make
decisions they actually decide to go
down one path or another based on
information and we're getting to a stage
now where we can start to ask those
kinds of very difficult questions so
again I think the engagement of some of
the physicists mathematicians are going
to be very important and I know I sound
like a broken record on this but very
important that we take biology to this
convergent step so we
engage these broader teams finally I
think that you know the dynamics and
information content that we need to
figure out in terms of cellular
communication it were just on the just
on the edge of that and so things like
chemical gradients what are what are
signals in cancer and chemical gradients
is only one way to sell signal but there
are lots and lots of other ways and
those signaling nodes are really what we
need to go after in terms of
understanding how information is
transferred finally these pathways for
cancer are extremely robust evolution
has actually selected for them so we
need to describe that robustus so we can
understand how we can overcome it and
they're vietnamese robust pathways are
selected for and selected for and
selected for every time we give a drunk
you need to also begin to define the
information that defines metastatic
disease so we won't we won't cure about
aesthetic disease until we understand
where does the information reside how is
the information transferred and how can
we stop it and I think that's going to
be key in also you know what is the
physics of these processes around
information finally cancerous tissue to
an Oregon specific and we need really to
put more of our effort on understanding
the structural information in the
infrastructure that is that is the
tissues and the cells that actually
translate what comes from the genome
very very important big community in our
cancer world and I think they're going
to make an enormous amount of progress
in the next few years maybe we need a
Cancer Genome Project for the
microenvironment it wouldn't be
surprised so I'm going to stop there we
have about 15 minutes left for questions
you can send your questions in and we'll
try to answer them and I'm going to go
some of you have already put some
questions up and I want to I want to
take some of those on now
and then we'll we'll come back and close
so here's a comment that is long but let
me see if I can get it so it's a
question about secondhand smoke it says
is the number of cancers tributed to
smoking taking into account secondhand
smoke and the fact that a third world
smoker so there's a very long question
are smoking poor cigarettes lower grade
of cigarettes that's a very interesting
question I don't know the answer to the
quality of the cigarette issue but I do
know that the number i gave you does not
under does not include the issue of
secondhand smoke I'm only talking about
primary smokers so that's uh that's
another problem and a very big problem
obviously for the families of these
folks so so x is a second question on
biomarkers here talking about bio marks
that the gallatin biomarkers except
protein biomarkers for complicated
pathways how reasonable is it to study
pathway gene expression biomarkers will
NVDA accept these kinds of research
efforts the answer is yes because i
think i think expression biomarkers are
going to be very important in terms of
pathway biology very difficult to
actually interpret very difficult to
really understand and correlate with
changes in disease but I think there is
I think we're entering an era where we
can with our computational friends begin
to develop algorithms to capture the
amount of information that would be an
expression profile and there are people
working on that so I think this is a
great area I think it's one that we
should not underestimate but we do need
to think about some of the practical
considerations of standardizing the
approaches and the best practices the
guidelines which many of you have worked
on over the years we don't need to
reinvent a lot of wheels here so so the
answer is yes very important as a matter
of fact I think may
more important most important may be of
some of the bio signature issues so are
we collecting data from thyroid cancer
patients as well I haven't mentioned it
I haven't mentioned a lot of cancers but
thyroid cancer actually is you know very
serious problem and yes there are
several groups collecting a lot of
information on thyroid cancers I don't
believe I don't have the data in front
of me I don't believe that I think we
have tissues for the Cancer Genome Atlas
for the thyroid cancer I don't think
that cancer has been has been run by the
group's yet it was not in the top 20 but
there are several groups that have that
our sequencing thyroid tissues and I
think we will have good I think we will
have good data on thyroid cancer it's a
really interesting one and and
essentially one that we should be
looking at more carefully it is it is a
big problem in certain countries more so
than in the US so my favorite question
what is the four-dimensional gene well
it's my term for what we need to do and
and it's a bit of a play on words
granted but if you think about the way
we're thinking about the genome today
essentially if you lay out a sequence
and I don't know how many of you have
looked at a genome sequence but probably
a lot of you have by now you know we're
laying out a lot of zeros and ones
essentially is what we're reading from
the genome visual information in two
dimensional two dimensional space so
what I'm asking us to do is to think
about moving up in terms of thinking
about four dimensional genomes in the
sense that let's think about let's think
about the genome in space three
dimensional space and over time which
would be the fourth aspect so
essentially it's a way to to bring
together the functionalization of the
genome so I think I you know I'm quoting
this phrase I don't know if I coined it
to someone or somebody else coined it
but i like it and hopefully we could
pick up on it and start thinking about
how to really delve into the
four-dimensional genome not just the
two-dimensional gel we're right now into
the four-dimensional genome producing
lots of big data but
we predict there's going to be a lot of
progress and that especially in
understanding that that configuration
between sort of spatial issues and how
how information is transferred between
the architecture of the cell and and the
digital changes that occur in the genome
and it's a little bit I think it's hard
for us to wrap our mind around the fact
that the genome is digital information
it is zeros and ones it's it's it's very
much like a computer program and it's an
extraordinarily complex computer program
we know something about it but we need
to know a lot more and there's a lot and
when a genome voxel actually that we
don't know probably then we do know so
how could it this is how can you get
involved and help to achieve your vision
of how cancer is defeated well there are
so many ways they would take me a lot
more than the 89 minutes I have left
here to tell you but if you're if you're
a scientist then I hope that you're
working in this space of accelerating
progress against cancer whether it's in
the basic science space which i believe
is incredibly important I think a lot of
our advances are going to come from
fundamental science in the future
whether it's in a translational space
and you think about how do you actually
develop very very high quality
biomarkers or how you develop very very
excellent drugs if you're in that if
you're in the farm industry or if you're
in the clinical trial space how do you
do better clinical trials if you're a
patient there are over 800 survivors
groups out there that you can get
engaged with if you're a professional
society then we're you know we're
focusing on everything for example in
the american association for cancer
research work put more focus on policy
we're focused on basic science
translational science clinical science
so there are so many ways and and
finally make sure that you're talking to
Congress about supporting cancer
research because right now NIH and NCI
overall are taking a big hit and we need
our we need our fundamental science
to be supported we need our clinical
investigators to be supported so one of
the things that everybody can do is
write a letter and say we want to
support research so there's a question
here that is one that is is a very big
deal and I want to really worries me a
lot and that is this issue of most
cancers are diagnosed in late stages
specifically stomach cancer when
possible stomach cancer is in fact
treatable now but not as treatable as we
would like is in an advanced stage so
this question that that's brought up
here is a really critical one is how do
we actually find this tumor earlier it's
a it's a similar problem that we have
with pancreatic cancer or GBM and others
and I think now with with with gastric
cancer especially and it is an
accessible cancer certainly you can you
can you can take biopsies you can do
work with sumit cancer that you can't do
with so many other cancers and so I am
hopeful for stomach cancer and it's by
the way its emerging again in this
country I mean you should know it's
caused by h pylori its emerging again as
a problem in this country and in younger
people we don't know why particularly
but it is and I am hopeful that we'll
use this very powerful genomics tool
that we have to begin to find those very
key genomic changes and we can start
looking for this tool or much earlier
and I think you just one that we can
start to look at in much much earlier
than we are now and I'm hopeful on that
cancer as I'm hopeful on everything but
I think Esther cancer is one of those
where we can do a great deal more the
next question is do I see a link between
cancer and autoimmune disease well I
trained as an immunologist so I tend to
see a link between immunity and almost
everything autoimmune disease as you
know is extraordinary problem producing
a whole range of diseases I don't know
the answer to your question in terms of
is there
direct link but there are certainly
diseases where we have a proliferation
of cells and and some of these pathways
I think maybe overlapping and the whole
issue of the immune system in cancer
overall is coming together and this last
year has kind of been a year for
immunotherapies I didn't mention as I
was going through that last couple
slides but FDA actually approved since
july of 2013 and are 12 and up to today
has approved 11 new cancer drugs that's
amazing two and two immunotherapies so
immunotherapy and this whole issue of
using the immune system is becoming very
mainstream and very effective and the
understanding of the intersection of
autoimmunity in cancer i think is going
to be very important maybe not for all
cancers but potentially for some cancers
but at the moment we don't have that
many people working in the space so if
you are working in that space I wish you
luck I think it's a very hard it's a
very hard area they're hard problem that
one that has a long promise so another
question is a public linkedin community
project a good idea is we have already
started one would you help us I'll help
anybody is you know me I'm very much the
constantly volunteer I have a day job
but I'll help anybody I love the
linkedin idea i think it's very
important and would be a way to get you
know get credentials out there and we
know people we could turn to for help so
the next question is long our continuum
models that consider unsteady state
diffusion and chemical reaction useful
to analyze and our continuum models that
consider unsteady state diffusion and
chemical reaction useful to analyze and
interpret some of the large databases
that you mentioned and have there been
significant advances in quantifying the
kinetics of tumor growth let me answer
the first questions first the answer is
yes this whole issue of the continuum
that you're talking about in terms of
cancer isn't is not at equilibrium this
is an unsteady state and its
one that lends itself to the model what
you're talking about so I would say yes
the Mongoose you're talking about would
be a very high value in the cancer space
especially in terms of some of the big
data you're talking about for some of
the cancers that have that have great
promise to be analyzed in this way and
then have there been significant
advances in quantifying the kinetics of
tumor growth I think kinetics in the way
that you're talking about it not as much
as we would like we do understand some
better I think some tumors better than
others but in terms of having a real
handle and predictability on tumors in
terms of kinetics not yet but I think as
we involve more physicist I think we
will get there we're on charming a lot
of questions which do you think will
play a greater part in demonstrating the
value proposition of personalized
medicine I think it will be diagnostics
and I'll stop there and I'll say that's
the biggest that's the biggest barrier
we have but I think it could be also be
the most productive because it has the
biggest payoff assuming we identify the
right patients for the right drugs any
comments on the unusable models to study
the evolution of the genome very
powerful very useful and I'm hoping we
see more of it in the space and that's a
repetitive question can i comment on the
role of computational experts with
protein biomarker discovery very very
important some of the major advances in
this space will be made by computational
experts working in the proteomics space
it is as close as we're going to get to
the state space and understanding the
state space state space of cancer so
drug treatment pushes cancer the
progression and your own resistance
which is a major change mutations what
do we need to obtain approval of the
diagnostics and run together you need
reproducibility and you need
predictability and obviously you need
efficacy and I I think that that will
become more predictive as we
better in the diagnostic space so before
I run out of time I want to just look at
the last list of questions and see
here's an interesting one how do i see
emotional factors in terms of cancers
complexity I wish we knew the answer
that we know that stress and other
issues are important but we don't know
why I wish more of our scientific
community wouldn't look at that it's
very difficult to study for
predisposition to cancer is
prophylactics it's prophylaxis promising
promising extraordinarily difficult so
I'm going to stop there i didn't get to
every question i'm sorry about that but
you ask a lot of great questions i am
optimistic that that molecular vice
therapy is is going to take us much
further than we are in terms of
defeating cancer is it the ultimate
answer I think it could be if in fact we
engage the communities that I spoke
about to bring everyone to the
conversation and understand this
four-dimensional genome how the genomics
is actually interpreted in people so
thank you very much for joining me today
and have a great day
you